now politicians have been talking a lot  recently haven't they about the uk  shortage of those hgv drivers  looks as though the labour leader zakir  starmer may be waiting some time before  he gets the call up look at  this and then when that lines up  oops shakir was on a visit to oldham  yesterday took a spin in a lorry but he  crashed the vehicle while reversing it  put it into dear oh dear in front of all  of the cameras put it into neutral make  sure it doesn't lurch forward  he'd hit that metal fence  and was told by his instructor then  where am i putting it he would have  failed his test if he'd been doing it  for real the rhode haulage association  estimates that there are around a  hundred thousand lorry driver jobs uh  going right now  he won't be getting one he went to have  a quick look about the damage  having run into  that metal pole  quick look yeah we can t cut that out  uh sakia  not looking for a career change any time